every place in the world sounds unique
these soundscapes
tell us a story about that place they
tell us the ways in which global warming
is beginning to change the natural
soundscape just before the Sun rises at
first light is the dawn chorus the birds
begin to sing and the insects and the
amphibians that's the time of day to go
out and listen I'm a soundscape
ecologist they record animals for a
living this is Sugarloaf State Park
every spring I can probably be found
there once a week recording in the same
spot using the same kind of equipment so
that I can repeat these recordings over
and over again and compare them and I
have quite a archive of material which
shows over time this habitat has been
changing pretty radically there's a
result of global warming and the
California drought
the first recording made in 2004 shows a
very robust habit added with a signature
of a stream in 2014 things were changing
radically it was already the second year
of a major drought in California and in
2015 we had what I call a Silent Spring
over 50% of my collection comes from
habitats that are so radically altered
they are either altogether silent or no
longer be heard in their original form
here's an example from Costa Rica
that's before logging this is after
same spot this is a coral reef the new
allez-vous and Fiji part of it is dying
and part of it is still living here's
what the living part sounds like here's
what the dying part sounds like
hardly any fish sounds
we really don't know what this means in
the long run in the short run were
beginning to lose these soundscapes
because the habitats are just changing
so radically and we're partly to blame
for them when I first began to record
almost fifty years ago I would go out
into the field and just put on a pair of
earphones and sit and listen because it
made me feel good it made me aware of
the living world around me and so I want
to do anything that does that for me
you